hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the steam release of
granny chapter 2 the last time I played
this it was on the ippity
and the controls were not very to my
advantage but now we are on my full
powered computer on and both grandma and
grandpa are going to get a bat to the
head I'm gonna smash their skulls it's
ok they're immortal they'll just come
back I'm gonna destroy you in every way
shape or form I'm gonna paint the walls
with your blood or I'm gonna fail but
I'm gonna finish it we're gonna be good
ok so the first step is just getting
familiar over the house because last
time I didn't think I was gonna win I
was very far from winning but this time
we're gonna take this calm collected
cool and just really just soak in though
hi really what did I do
I am in bed grandma I am in bed at some
point you're going to give me brain
damage if I don't have it already
oh I'm being kidnapped why am I being
kidnapped oh I wasn't at your house
grandma I see
I see I was I was in my home
you are not my grandma I get it now I
get it now I get it now yeah the thing
is I don't remember there being a
cutscene last time I just remember
getting into it let's um let's get this
done right so the first objective is
just to not be caught by these [ __ ]
who called himself at my grandparents
all right here we go let me just get
used to the controls okay are to hide
okay all right nothing in here
I hear someone stomped around
I don't know what the hell that is all
about grandma why would you have that
song playing it's awfully pertinent to
the situation and also you seem to be
awfully self-aware that people don't
want to be at your house which is
additionally weird I don't know if this
is like the only hiding place but it
feels safe feels good feels real good
there are two sets of footprints
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't
know what the growling was and I don't
want to know oh god everything is fine
why was I in a panic I don't know what
the deal is well no one needs to be in a
tizzy I know I don't actually be flow /
why the bear traps okay no you didn't
see you didn't see y'all you saw that's
a funny thing to say considering you
didn't actually see me you gonna [ __ ]
out a bear trap well this is problematic
they're awfully quiet I can barely hear
them walking around
okay there's grandma
okay
Oh grandpa sleeping
can I get the key
he's got up what the [ __ ]
okay um
okay she's coming Oh God oh that's not
good well that what is this where am i
where am i oh my god what is this what
is this no I don't know what this is
Kenny it a wrench okay so I've got a key
I managed to nab the security key which
i think is a bold move glad I did it
someone's looking for me
grandpa's in the security room I guess
what's this all about okay I didn't know
that you were also here oh boy oh good I
just wake up what happened to the
security key then is it dropped in the
water oh God
I bet Grampy just has it back god damn
it I didn't know that was gonna be a
thing I didn't know that was the thing
at all I didn't even know that was
possible
I'll limp now my leg being mangled no
everything's gonna be different or is it
I don't know ooh
no you know what actually I'm I you
don't need to the thing is Grampy
funnily enough I put myself to bed
ignore the blood trail what'd you say I
couldn't understand you you were kind of
gibbering I've got a stun gun that's
good that's good stun guns good stun
guns good I could probably stun someone
I could probably definitely stun someone
if I needed to I don't know how many
shots I have I'm guessing just one I
remember there's like a new bad luck key
that's important just like a yeah
there's a secret little nook here which
is good and then there's a crowbar
which is important first stuff leave the
you got there pick up the crowbar a
wrench
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god everything is fine everything is
complete
hey Bob hey Grammy Grammy Graham they're
both up here great okay so there was a
thing outside that needed the wrench
yeah okay wasn't there like I should
have known I should have known I should
have known that I was going to fool
myself then I was just going to be a
robust fool about it
oh ho [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh they're
coming for me Oh God not today grandma
please please you didn't see the door
was closed I could be anywhere but not
in here
definitely not in here I could be
anywhere else but in this room oh I'm
hungry
good for you man good for you you always
gotta stay hungry for it you know can't
let that hunger die yeah constantly
strive for greatness
or else what will you have nothing wise
words wise words I think that sparkplug
goes in the engine
[Music]
downstairs I was the growling about why
is it in the walls okay well there's
that didn't I see the padlock key also
come on I'll be ridiculous ucch
oh god no no no oh well that's dumb Oh
God god dammit oh god dammit I I think
I'm I bones this one up real good i
bones did real good
I did I did a lot of dumb alright last
day last day best day this is the day
I'm gonna get it I know exactly what I'm
doing I know exactly how to do it I'm
gonna show these stupid a-holes who is
the boss turns out I am NOT the Baus oh
well I'm dumb how are you gonna kill me
oh I got one more day okay that's right
last day best day this is the last day
and it will be my best day I'm gonna
nail this this is gonna be great
this is gonna be the one gonna stun one
of them not gonna go down without a
fight
oh alright well that's useful
granny's now gone for one minute okay
good Oh what is this since when did they
have a screen in patio Oh God a Kroeber
okay
where'd the Kroeber go where did oh
where did I put the crowbar
oh you can just do it over and over
again oh my god really really oh god why
the [ __ ] painting distracted me oh
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh really this
one yeah well you know you could just
close it with your hands why you got to
do it like this yep dad that one hurt
down hurt both my my heart and my
feelings that's what really gets to me
okay we're gonna try this again this
time I've got it [ __ ] you are silent
take your slippers off grandpa oh that
got me good Jesus where did you come
from
man heaven both of them around it's just
like such a bigger challenge I can't
hear them well I can hear grandma's
can't hear Grampy dammit meat
why would oh that's not good that's the
opposite of good oh Jesus
I think I'm not good at this game I
think I'm not good the stun gun a well
la-dee-da I have the stun gun
[Music]
what do you will get to me then she can
get to me ah yeah got ya
I'll take that yeah you're gone Grampy
where's grandpa i'ma shoot grandpa wang
going uh give me those and I'll take
that as well okay well that makes it
easier if I can just shock him out of
this universe I have that by the way let
me go I'm just gonna go get this
upstairs and in the lock if I have
unlimited stun gun there's gonna be a
lot easier
whoa I'm just gonna get the stun gun
don't know what that is whose grunting
whose groaning why Oh slender okay oh my
I have a stun gun but that's interesting
that is most certainly interesting door
lock is there that's a good place for it
actually that's a good place wrench I
think I know where this is oh [ __ ] I
think they're back already already okay
so this is definitely down here I don't
have my gun anymore though
wrench yes did that put a bridge over
the water so I won't die if I go in it
[Music]
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god you cannot get me in
here law says you cannot law was right
by the legal laws of law you can't come
down here grandma's just like yeah that
hope no you can't make me I'm your
grandma well you know you kidnap me you
can't do it get out of here I won't I'm
in a hole all right anyway
did you just [ __ ] out another bear trap
in the same place you did you put two
bear traps you [ __ ]
Wow okay you know what no not not no not
even a little bit nope no big ol no on
that one
[Music]
where's the stun gun it's right here
it's right here
come on Graeme come on Graeme
Clemmy where you at Graeme here you want
a piece of me Grammy Grammy Grammy
Grammy
[Music]
goodbye Grammy anything in here gasoline
that's for the boat I believe Oh uh-huh
uh-huh now you die this is the best this
is I don't care if there's cheese and uh
so what was it with it oh well oh all
right then
okay well that's that's good to know
they're good to know
I don't know what that does but okay
maybe the electricity downstairs
maybe oh [ __ ]
okay let's go to the security room so
now I know what the whoops okay oh god
no I don't want that what did I just get
a wheel sure yeah
okay okay okay I'm up here now I don't
think they can come up here Kenny
he's some kind of key what what Keyes's
boat key it's given me a lot of boat
stuff so you know maybe I should listen
[Music]
just listen okay
it's the beeping all about Robert
Kurvers here oh I'm falling I don't want
to fall no no not not like this I need
out no no no please not on top of Grammy
not up run not right on top of her okay
gonna fall it's okay
[Music]
hey Grammy sorry had to do it to you you
know how it is you know what's up Grammy
you know what day to day basis you know
the stress of my life hand wheel hand
wheel the hand wheel for I'm need to go
get that Kroeber who's laughing you
laughing soon like blast you full of ten
thousand volts
Oh grip grandma's corpse is still there
well there she goes
let's go up again let's drop the crowbar
down the hole or not okay
oh we're being silly are we alright okay
you've been ridiculous
there we go anything else up here that I
need what is that what is that it's like
something chained up probably bad
who's playing piano
that sounds quick who's coming up yeah
yeah around two or three
I forget which round it is you've been
losing so many no oh well yeah hate to
see it oh well she'll never recover so
sad oh god no not like this no God God
of course of course I have the key to
victory and I still manage to screw up I
still manage it how I'm an idiot
there you go I'm an idiot I have the key
to everything
and I still screw up wow I am I am livid
you are really gonna camp it I don't
care what Grammy says I don't care what
Grammy tries to do I'm going for it oh
[ __ ]
you'll never know you'll never know
where did I go impossible to tell no one
could know no one will ever know don't
go that way why would you go that way
this is bigotry of the highest magnitude
okay alright that is Dickens
oh you know you spider [ __ ] no you suck
so bad how did this happen how did this
happen I had the ultimate weapon and I
still managed to [ __ ] it up I can't
believe that I cannot believe it
[Music]
[Applause]
alright let's do it again
I need that stun gun I need it I need it
I want it I want the gun give me the gun
I think the Bell causes them to go like
feed the kid quote-unquote
okay did that I don't know what that did
oh my god oh my god yes oh baby we in it
now
come up here yeah Here I am sorry there
you go grandma are you coming up from
behind yeah come on gramma oh oh no oh
no oh looks like I am about to own this
whole house Oh looks like this house is
mine grandma Oh looks like you are being
evicted oh it looks like you haven't
paid your rent in a while oh no grandma
sorry I didn't mean to step over your
corpse like that oh that's such a shame
for you oh no the security room is open
oh gosh someone needs to stop this
menace this horrible man that's just
terrorizing your entire place this bad
grandson
oh no but who will stop him no one you
say oh say it ain't so say it ain't so
say so it ain't so okay there's a button
there oh I wonder oh I just had a
thought
as risky that could have been horrible
I gotta lost that forever um I need
cutting plus i have cutting wires you
love to see it you love you love to see
it I don't know how these are so sharp
to cut chain but you just absolutely
love to see it you love to see it oh it
is whoa what the [ __ ] Nosferatu better
not get up you're gonna get up what is
this door handle okay I don't know what
I just unleashed whoo okay goodbye
okay don't look at me like what the [ __ ]
you just had that up in your what okay I
got a door handle okay I'm assuming this
is for like the front door or something
you know I'm not gonna go down there
without this
huh huh you see me oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] you're gonna you're gonna go there
I'm gonna come back for that I'm not
gonna ooh I'm gonna come back for the
ammo I'm gonna come back for the ammo oh
where are you going now God is it gonna
be under the bed what do I do
Oh God you spider Rudy
God why oh of course they were both
gonna come after me god damn it that's
so stupid
there's the Emma I think he's still in
there are you kidding me
the [ __ ] is wrong with you the [ __ ] was
that
is there some kind of [ __ ]
programming that's like nah he's got the
stun gun we have to right [ __ ] there
give it and you go down you hag I'll zap
your body I don't care
I'll do it again oh yeah I forgot the
safe keys here okay
I'm gonna drop the safe key down the
hole
dony a hell of a limp it's not gonna
throw off my aim a joint sorry
I've got this door handle here um just
gonna take it downstairs real quick well
I still have some time
that right there safe I think that was
in the shower I think that lands in the
shower I'm not I'm sure I'm just making
sure I got that gun with me no matter
what if I don't have that gun I am very
very very upset okay so I do have the
meet weird lady well there you are
welcome back and goodbye so where I
chuck the meet didn't I check the meet
down here somewhere
thought I did not
no I didn't thought I did didn't I
I could have sworn I did but barely I
didn't where you at old man I hear you
yeah good for you
alright YouTube YouTube YouTube YouTube
voltea both of you get out of here what
do I do
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa do
not do that I shoot you I put meat in
there oh god oh god oh god oh god you
know what you suck what are you
I put meat in there I don't know if that
does anything though
I might've screwed that up okay whatever
it's not important I need to get the
crowbar again cuz there's a box
downstairs that I still need to open
this still needs to go down there this
needs to go down there where's the
crowbar hey grandma you got any more
meat
[Music]
where the [ __ ] did he come from I was
looking
did he just spawn there is that how
goddamn unlucky I am he just spawned
there oh my god
alright last day I had better get this
just give me the gun man grandma where
are you oh god damn it it didn't have
any ammo go my god I have to start over
ah [ __ ] I was right there too I had to
have been right there if I get that I
get the last things I'm gonna need to
finish the goddamn game and then oh my
god I can't believe it's my fault for
forgetting that there was no ammo in
there but let's not forget too that that
was a real dick move it's hard to tell
if they're on the same floor or not I
think they're checking the noises
downstairs okay that is just patently
unfair that is I can't tell if they're
above me or below me I just can't tell
it's so difficult
alright but I'm gonna go get this
shotgun and I'm going to blast the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of the both of you
oh it is time to show these loving
grandparents a real real good time Oh
Grammy grandma MA Grammy Dearest oh
there you are
[ __ ] off
oh no I shot grandma what you gonna do
about Pappy hey Pappy you're worried
about that
alright so says you grandpappy doesn't
seem to care poor grandma but really
like a [ __ ] shotgun blast only does
30 seconds more than a stun gun
[ __ ] off [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me god dammit the
[ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] there's a squeak right there all
right okay okay okay okay all right okay
all right okay all right okay okay all
right that's how it's gonna be
oh that works okay I don't have the wire
cutters god damnit I think more bullets
just spawn when you have them I'm still
gonna [ __ ] shoot you come to get you
Grundy where you got Grampy and your
[ __ ] off because I now have the stun gun
and also the [ __ ] crowbar AME what I
need you to look [ __ ] good I've never
been happier
okay that goes there I'm taking the curl
bar though I'm not done with you no no
not by a long shot
it looks like maybe the boat yeah
whatever [ __ ] off who cares oh the
cutting pliers I do need these where did
the gun go where'd the gun go oh there
it is I almost got scared no no I've got
a minute I'm gonna go cut the things
that I need I'm gonna come right back
down that's it
cut this thing and then up here
lightning fast just do it and get down I
should be fine get up get up get up get
up get up get up get up do the things do
the things I need to do I don't have
time to waste around what's in here it's
the safe key good great love that love
it Love Actually okay and then go back
down I need the I need
it's done good I am not safe without the
stun gun
so what do I have
there's some stuff upstairs this is the
padlock key great no no thank you
get stopped undulating
okay so I've got the boat key
I've got gasoline which I am imagining
is for the boat right okay right okay
okay okay
and then I've got the gasoline and they
give a pokey and then I've did I get a
spark plug at some point I feel like I
did I don't want to be up here too long
because I feel like they're just gonna
spawn all on top of me okay getting out
of here oh hi you were very quiet you
trying to sneak up on me yeah it was
that door handle okay spark plug here
comes the next one yeah come on where
are you oh yeah you heard something yeah
you were right you heard something yeah
that's weird okay now I'm just gonna I'm
gonna run these down and got him bolt
chuck him over the edge chuck him down
chuck it down what is this over here
safety I don't need that um where's the
boat wheel did I get the boat wheel I
don't remember or anything else I left
down here I don't know
okay I've got spark plug gas the
crowbars down here where'd the key go
should be sparkling right there
goddammit you know I forgot one where
would the boat wheel be did I see it I I
know I've seen the boat wheel I just
don't remember where I think I got the
cutting pliers from there yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep okay now I should be
able to just run these down okay spark
plug got it
key in the ignition this is the last
thing okay
that's the last thing gasps okay
so I need the padlock for that I think
that's important
I need the boat wheel and then the
padlock key my gramma
that sucks for you Paul very nearly got
me there grandpa bamps not this time
okay where was the padlock II have I
seen it is it somewhere up here there's
meat I might need to go feed the beast
is the thing I might need to do that but
I'm just gonna double-check around here
oh the door lock I don't need that I'm
not going for that exit here's the hand
wheel oh I think I know what that is I
think I just remembered something from
before good okay so I think the hand
wheel is right here not a hard sensor
what it's for but I did that so where
what does that do I don't remember what
did that do I have no idea must have
changed something upstairs or
out of them oh what the oh that oh [ __ ]
um okay
well am i closer to that then wait am I
am i closer to that one that I am I
haven't found the boat wheel so okay
maybe maybe maybe I am maybe I am I
don't know I think I've found some good
stuff am i I guess I found the door
handle I just need Oh God really really
your corpse is gonna undulate oh the pad
lucky I am
wait I am closer to this one I think I'm
so close I think I'm right here
wait okay so [ __ ] this handle right
there padlock right here right there
boys just go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I did it I thought I was close
to the boat oh my god yes finally God
that only took it two hours two hours
for Chapter two baby either way that is
granny chapter two some spooks some
frustrations some funky mechanics but
all in all there's something very
appealing about this game it's it's not
like polished is the thing but it's
intricate and the mechanics are very
straightforward and out of a lot of
games you can't always say that like
it's an adventure every playthrough is
different and just having that makes it
interesting
so that's granny thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below if you
want to see other videos of granny like
granny chapter one or other scary games
they're linked in the description or
there and the suggested videos down
there
thank you again subscribe for more ring
the bell ringing the bell you know you
want to be fed you got to ring that Bell
ding dong and thanks again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]